thanks for playing Jesse's girl nice
you're not sick of that are you no
matter what call me tonight and sing it
together now first of all a bunch of
things to talk about but this is you do
this movie curse yeah and you got to
work with Scott Baio in this movie is it
vayu or bio I'm always confused I think
he prefers bio okay well those Baio
but you work with him and what's
interesting is that you're of an age
were like you'd be a big fan of his
yeah very young guy that's right yeah
any but yeah me and younger watch
Charles in Charge
right yeah grow up watching that so you
grow up watching Charles in charge and
this is something I've found that when
you when you're young and you see people
on TV they become your idols and I've
you know working on this show got to
meet a lot of really famous big movie
stars but then I'll just meet someone
like Don Knotts who was in Mayberry you
know then I watched now as a kid and
that's bigger to me is that Baio to you
is like the biggest star in the world
and no existed until like actually some
of the set right just kind of mythic
right right god of dancers
oh but a crazy thing to say see you also
worked with elizabeth berkley I know
you're a fan of Saved by the Bell
no well there's the difference you watch
Saved by the Bell when you were how old
probably 10 okay when I was watching it
I was like 28 years old studio apartment
eating cereal out of a bowl and watching
it and feeling like a pervert right I
just didn't know what that was yeah yeah
yeah you just weren't sure what it was
always felt like so so so so Scott you
got your Scott Baio you have your
elizabeth berkley it's for your age like
who else would be a huge star for you to
work with Conan O'Brien oh that's nice
you've enjoyed my work in Edward
Scissorhands I understand you were more
gone yeah
now what about okay you do this movie in
cursed and it required a nude scene
that's in the movie but you it wasn't
your body is that right no no they were
trying to sell tickets well so was that
your choice did you did you say to them
I want to use my body for the nude scene
or was it their idea that there'd be
another body there for the nude scene I
think it would be you know any rational
persons idea that would be another body
right I showed up on this I didn't
realize like actual it's actually a like
a stunt in the movie I wake up naked in
the bushes cuz in the movie I'm I'm
affected by a werewolf I'm bit by a quad
by a werewolf so Mary so anyway so of
course I would wake up in the bushes and
uh and we then I I going to push his
next to my house and I climb back in my
house naked right so I just you know I
you read the script you kind of just my
eyes kind of gloss over and I read like
stunts cuz like you know if see that's
the thing if I was reading that script
and it was my part and I said anything
about being nude I would immediately
panic and withdraw from the project
I heard you demanded a rewrite yeah yeah
demand a rewrite that I'd be fully
clothed like worried extra clothes at
all time so so so this you meet this guy
whose job it is to be you naked yeah
what was he like he was actually having
sex with my girlfriend at the time
[Laughter]
[Applause]
conversation for you excuse me pardon
yeah yeah what what's his name
his name is actually a miss chaste penny
what that's not a name that's something
you do they really do yeah right right
penny I love that he came up with he was
like I'm a stunt I'm a nude model I'm
gonna be I'm gonna call myself chase
penny that's right
and but was he an enhancement of your
body did you find or an exact replica
replica yeah you can only be an
enhancement oh no no don't be sorry to
track for my own body [ __ ] you and I are
both very self-hating I've always
thought if I wasn't a movie and I had to
be nude and they picked a stunt double I
would just get like this incredibly this
person that didn't match me at all like
dark olive skin you know to my face
[Laughter]
doesn't exist stunt guys who looked like
well speak to myself like me right right
right there should be there should be I
know we need this not fair so you're
getting your you're in bigger and bigger
films you know and and this movie curse
can be seen by a lot of people you're
starting to get recognized you're trying
to have people notice you are you
getting used to
I found the hardest thing initially
wasn't people on the street noticing me
it was just like reading about myself
yeah you know like you pick up a
newspaper and they talk about you and
you think like wait a minute that's me
how could I be in the newspaper are you
getting used to reading about yourself
like I haven't entered a newspaper it's
kind of like I've extended as far as
internet blogs but um but yeah I mean
they're they're malicious you know it's
anonymous
you're reading your inner the Internet
bugs and say things about yours I'm not
I would never do that
well so so you read that what I mean
that's very gutsy because you know there
it's malicious it's their guts it's
people you know it's anonymous so of
course you know the you know it
increases how malicious they are right
right they're all funny there was a guy
was on a website and it was like they
somebody wrote in that that that I'm
ugly that's right they said ugly and
then and then the next few comments were
like we're kind of discussing the degree
of ugliness like they
the minute I saw ugly I would I would
log off or go look at porn or something
I wouldn't but you're sticking your like
they say I'm ugly and then you stay in
the game look at the poor man I came
back that's terrible that's terrible you
shouldn't read that stuff I know it's
it's addictive you're a you're a fine
looking fellow and you're doing very
well you're a very funny guy and it was
very nice to have you on the show it's
an honor to be here well it's not an
honor but let's say it is clearly you
have me confused with someone else
cursed is in theaters now and I really
hope you'll come back because you're
really fun to talk to thank you
[Applause]